what's the future of earth not humanity
broadly
but earth specifically conversations
about interplanetary expansion are dime
a dozen in silicon valley
mostly thanks to the work elon musk is
doing at spacex
everyone pretty much assumes that
humanity will expand from earth to mars
before moving on to the outer planets
and moons this process of solar
expansion has been described in many
science fiction stories
my favorite of which has to be the
expanse but what about earth
specifically
regardless of whether or not certain
groups of humans move on to other
planets or solar systems
it seems reasonable to assume that earth
will continue to grow as an ecosystem
for life
barring of course an extinction level
event i'm john coogan
and here's what earth could look like in
the future in the middle of 2020
some researchers at the strelka
institute created a framework for
analyzing the future of earth
instead of looking at various
technological developments and trying to
analyze how they might compound
they instead focused entirely on energy
consumption
energy consumption is an extremely
useful metric for understanding
civilizational progress
in 1964 nikolai kardashev created a
quantitative scale to describe three
different types of civilizations
a type 1 civilization would be able to
access
all of the energy available on its
planet for reference
humanity is currently around 0.6 and
should reach type 1 in the next couple
of hundred years
type 2 would be a civilization capable
of harnessing
all of the energy of its home star while
doing this would be incredibly complex
freeman dyson hypothesized it would be
possible with a dyson sphere
could this be a dyson sphere the object
does fit the general parameters of
dyson's theory
a dyson sphere it's a very old theory
number one i'm not surprised that you
haven't heard of it
in the 20th century a physicist called
freeman dyson postulated the theory that
an enormous hollow sphere could be
constructed around a star
this would have the advantage of
harnessing all the radiant energy of
that start
any population living on the interior
surface would have
virtually inexhaustible sources of power
are you saying you think that people
living in there
possibly a great number of people
commander the interior surface area of a
sphere this size is the equivalent
of more than 250 million class m planets
a type 3 civilization basically controls
all of the energy in their entire galaxy
an alien race this advanced would
probably appear godlike to us
both type 2 and type 3 civilizations
require massive expansion beyond the
confines of earth
and could be thousands or even millions
of years away
but getting to type 1 is actually pretty
feasible for humanity if current trends
continue
humanity is currently producing 18
terawatts of electricity
placing us around 0.6 on the kardashev
scale
while 0.6 may appear close to 1 the
scale is logarithmic
so moving up one increment after the
point means 10 times the energy
to get to kardashev level 1 our energy
production
will need to be 10 000 times higher than
current levels
if we look backward at humanity's energy
production finding a time where humans
controlled 10 000 times
less energy than they do now requires
going back
more than 12 000 years to when we were
hunter-gatherers
but our growth in energy production is
exponential roughly two percent per year
so we're not twelve thousand years away
from reaching kardashev one
or k one levels if we extrapolate that
two percent annual growth rate into the
future
you can see that we should reach k1
levels of energy production
within the next 500 years but the exact
date that we reach
k1 depends a lot on the average growth
rate called gamma
that we assume for the future over the
last 150 years
the growth rate has been 2.6 percent but
that has slowed to just 2 percent
over the past 40 years regardless if
positive growth rates continue
meaning gamma is positive k1 is
inevitable
so how will ever increasing energy
consumption affect our planet
in order to answer this question we need
to consider the first law of
thermodynamics
energy can be transformed from one form
to another
but it can neither be created nor
destroyed
this means that the energy we use on
earth is inevitably released as waste
heat
before it's radiated into space this
would create another form of climate
change
completely separate from the greenhouse
effect and much harder to counteract
physicists estimate that a temperature
increase of 12 degrees centigrade
would create a doomsday scenario and at
k1 levels of energy consumption
the waste heat alone would raise earth's
temperature
past this doomsday level and require
massive structural changes
in the way our world operates in order
to survive
even if we rely on solar energy
exclusively earth will still reach a
direct heating doomsday
before reaching k1 levels of energy
consumption unfortunately
the laws of thermodynamics are
impossible to bypass directly
so we will have to adapt there are tons
of ways that earth could adapt
along the way to k1 but it's useful to
consider
two primary dimensions along which these
adaptations could occur the first
dimension
would be where we choose to use the
majority of our energy
on earth or in space pushing energy
usage into space via satellites
would allow the earth to maintain
livable temperatures while keeping
energy
consumption within the atmosphere would
require significant changes to life on
earth
the second dimension we should consider
would be the way in which we produce
energy
as this affects the direct heating
timeline if we choose to focus on solar
energy
and cover the planet in photovoltaic
cells earth becomes black
on the other end of this spectrum is a
blue earth where the majority of energy
is produced via fusion
and leaves some of earth's surface
available for other uses based on these
variables
we can imagine four extreme scenarios
each at the edges of these trade-offs
the first is black marble which
represents the scenario most affected by
direct heating
in this future humanity has been
extremely inefficient in energy
production
and unable to expand beyond our
atmosphere due to space junk
consequently the earth is now covered in
solar panels
and the entire society lives inside of a
dome
the earth is completely climate
controlled and the majority of humans
spend their time in virtual reality
much like the future depicted in ready
player one this outcome is possible if
we don't optimize our technologies
before it's too late
at a certain point once the effects of
direct heating are inevitable
the only solution is to use even more
energy to control the climate
artificially
the second scenario is the opposite of
the black marble
and we'll call it arcology this is a
future where most energy is used
off-earth
thanks to the development of
megastructures that extend into space
this leaves the remainder of the
planet's surface for agriculture
and the cultivation of biodiversity this
is an extremely efficient society
with just two billion human inhabitants
all focused on fighting against excess
entropy
in order to avoid destroying earth's
atmosphere from direct heating
industry is located on the moon where a
solar base
beams energy back to earth and new
energy intensive construction can be
completed off earth the third scenario
called half earth considers what the
world would be like if humans no longer
existed at all
on half earth an artificial general
intelligence runs the planet
which is entirely robotic this agi is
entirely focused on expansion at all
costs
and no longer needs to worry about
direct heating or earth's atmosphere at
all
the goal is to mine materials until the
construction of the first dyson sphere
can be completed
before moving on to other solar systems
and continuing to expand from there
this is the most aggressive scenario by
far with most energy generated by fusion
all resources are mere inputs helping to
expand and conquer the universe
the last scenario considers what would
happen if humans were able to evolve
into photo symbians
and overcome the limitations of
traditional human forms
photo symbians are genetically modified
humans that are capable of autotrophy
through photosynthesis this would
obviate the need for traditional farming
and allow humanity to use energy on
earth much more efficiently
in this world energy is abundant and
atmospheric engineering has
redistributed sunlight more evenly
across the planet's surface
allowing for higher biomass production
efficiency temperatures are level
across the earth's surface and one
trillion sentients are flourishing
in the tropical and subtropical zones
these four scenarios represent just
two different parameters the type of
energy production
and the location of its consumption as
you can see
these variables allow us to predict
radically different futures
and there are obviously many other
possible futures
so what's the takeaway here well this
type of parameter driven projection
methodology
is useful because it shows us that the
future is indeterminate and humanity
still has an incredible amount of agency
regarding how we progress as a species
it's quite common in silicon valley to
hear particular thought leaders
share singular visions of the future
often in service of the particular
project they are working on at the
moment
but i think it's more useful to imagine
multiple scenarios
and the decisions that might lead to
each one as for which future i think is
most likely
and which future i would most like to
see personally
i'll be covering that in a future video
so please consider subscribing
you